اذا بعض اكثر من عامل من الشد والجذب هو
تبادل الاتهامات قرر برهان في خطاب له
اليوم بوجود تفاهمات مع قوى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي قائلا ان القوات
المسلحه لمست فيها وطنيتهم والتزامهم بعدم
الرجوع للسلطان فيما يلي ابرز المحطات في
علاقات الجانبين في العشر من حزيران يونيو
الماضي وبعد طول انقطاع ان عقد بشكل مفاجئ
اجتماع بين تحالف في قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي وممثلين الجيش في مجلس
السياده لطلب من مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاجتماع لم يبدد الخلافات بين
الجانبين اذا شدد المجلس المركزي للحريه
والتغيير في الرابعه عشر من سبتمبر ايلولا
الماضي على ضروره دمج جميع القوات
الموازيه في جيش واحد وانهاء كل الانشطه
السياسيه الحزبيه داخل المؤسسات العسكريه
فقط واتهم المجلس المركزي لقوى الحريه
تغيير في الخامس عشر من سبتمبر عناصر
النظام السابق بمحاوله الوقيعه بين الجيش
والمدنيين وفي اليوم نفسه رد الجيش نافيا
اتهامات قوى الحريه والتغييره بوجود
انقلابيين في صفوفه مؤكدا قدرته على اتخاذ
ما يلزم لتامين البلاده وفي الرابعه عشر
من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي قالت مصادر
مدنيه وعسكريه ان المدنيين والعسكريين في
السودان توصلوا الى اتفاقنا ولي لمراجعه
اتفاقي جوبا للسلامه الموقع مع الحركات
المسلحه هذا المجلس المركزي للاقوى الحريه
والتغيير في السابعه عشر من اكتوبر ليقول
انه لم يجري اي مفاوضات مباشره مع المكونا
العسكري وفي الثاني والعشرين من شهر
اكتوبر فرحت قوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي رؤيتها لانهاء ما سمته لانقلاب
العسكري وخروج الجيش من السياسه في
السودان